it's great to welcome back to the
program Andrew Torres who's a graduate
of Harvard Law has been practicing law
for 21 years and co-hosts the opening
arguments show the legal podcast that
helps you make sense of the news Andrew
always great to have you on thank you oh
it's always great to be here David I I
love the show and thank you so much for
having me off so let's start talk start
talking about court packing this is
something I was hearing from my audience
a lot about in advance of the 2018
midterms we've had the midterms
Democrats will be taking over the house
when they are sworn in in January of
2019 so questioned it's sort of two-part
question to start
what is court packing and does
controlling the house have any
connection to whether Democrats can do
it okay so a great question first
court packing it comes from the fact
that the Constitution a lot of people
don't know this but article 3 section 1
of the Constitution just says that the
judiciary shall be vested in one Supreme
Court and in such inferior courts as
Congress may from time to time ordain
and establish so that means that not
only does Congress get to decide the
layout of the circuit courts of Appeal
but that has been interpreted
consistently since the nation's founding
that Congress gets to decide how many
people are on the Supreme Court it's
it's been 9 for a hundred and fifty
years but it hasn't always been not it's
been as low as 5 and as high as 10 and
so the idea is that with the Republicans
having weaponized the judiciary and they
have and I can you know get into that if
you'd like to go down that trail with
right-wing activists that one way to
combat that is to increase you know you
can't necessarily kick Neil Gorsuch and
Brett Kavanaugh off the Supreme Court
Supreme Court justices serve for quote
good behavior which is the same standard
they have to be impeached but maybe you
could add additional judges to the
Supreme Court to sort of counterbalance
that out so
court packing is then the question is
can you do it with just the House of
Representatives and the answer is no
right right and explain why I mean
ultimately it would still be up to the
President to choose who would serve on
an expanded Supreme Court and thus even
if you could expand the number of seats
it would still be whoever is in the
White House who would choose who gets
those seats so it almost is a moot
question in a sense so here's here's how
Democrats could pack the Supreme Court
because you're right I mean if the
Democratic Congress were to initiate a
bill to expand the Supreme Court in 2019
the Republicans would happily go along
with that right because the president
gets to a point the Supreme Court
justices so that that would be a
disaster this is what you would need to
do and I guess I'm going to do this in
sort of increasing order of difficulty I
don't know
first Democrats would need to win the
presidency keep the house and win the
Senate in 2020 that's not going to be an
easy challenge part of it is because the
way that you know the cycle of Senate
seats Democrats are going to need three
seats in order to flip the Senate
assuming that they win the presidency if
it's a democratic year they're probably
safely going to pick up two in Colorado
and in Maine that's Susan Collins
obviously and and Cory Gardner in
Colorado but they're probably going to
lose Jones's seat in Alabama which is a
deep red state they're unlikely to win
that again so you've got to pick off two
- Senate seats from you have to win all
the Democratic seats that are up I'm
assuming that and then you'd have to
pick up two more Republican seats from
states like North Carolina Joni Ernst in
Iowa Lindsey Graham at South Carolina if
that's a tough okay but suppose they do
that suppose they get 50 seats and
Elizabeth Warren wins the presidency
and they want to introduce and they keep
the house and they want to introduce a
bill that's what you would do you would
amend the Judiciary Act of 1861 and
you'd increase the number of seats on
the Supreme Court and so then because
obviously the Democrats aren't going to
get 60 seats no no matter what happens
in 2020 I don't think that's even
mathematically possible you would have
to blow up the filibuster and the
process for that is what was called the
nuclear option when the Senate passed a
limited version of that in terms of
allowing them to pass Obama's judges
over a filibuster in 2012 and that was
also what the Republicans used in 2017
to confirm Neil Gorsuch probably too
long to explain here I did an episode of
my show opening arguments it's episode
59 in which I explain the intricacies of
the rules but basically what happens is
the Senate can with a bare majority that
is 50 plus one the tie-breaking vote of
whoever our next president of Elizabeth
Warren's vice president is can change
the rules of the Senate and get rid of
the filibuster entirely they would need
to do that because obviously any
Republicans in the Senate even if it's a
minority would obviously oppose a court
packing bill and and then the third
thing you'd have to do is you'd have to
hold the line with those Democratic
senators and and the way in which I put
this to you know sort of mm-hmm
and again I'm a liberal guy I'm on the
Left I could talk for days about how the
Trump administration has weaponized the
Supreme Court we've activists right wing
judges but when I talk to my fellow
lefties I I say to them there is nothing
to stop the Republicans from doing this
right now right they've got four more
weeks to do that until the clocks run
out but they can do that right now and
and if your instinctive reaction is oh
well you know maybe Lisa Murkowski and
Jeff Flake would stop us
radiant stop them right like maybe who
knows but but that's what Republicans
would say right if if the Democrats have
a 50-seat majority they're gonna say
okay Joe Manchin is is our Lisa
Murkowski right
Kyrsten Sinema is is our
Jeff Flake so that's that that's the
that's the path in front of us in terms
of packing the court to try and take
back the judiciary it's a tough one I
think it would be easier to impeach a
specific Supreme Court justice than it
would be to to pack the course so that's
what I was sort of gonna go to next
which is short not impeachment but given
control of the House by Democrats from a
legal perspective what else can they do
we've talked about investigations and
we've yet sturdy on the program I kind
of gave a long list of different areas
and people and ways in which what has
transpired could be investigated
there's understandable skepticism and
cynicism about would it be any more than
just something to bug Trump with for two
years from a legal perspective what
would be most effective that would be
within the purview of a Democratic House
okay so so a lot of things there I'm
really glad you talked about
investigatory and oversight powers
yesterday I
I guess I kind of want to start with the
baseline right which is by controlling
the House of Representatives the
Democrats can stop Trump from passing
bad laws through the budget
reconciliation process like the tax cut
of 2017 right
that was crammed through at the end of
December they can now prevent that
because you need you know both houses to
affirm a bill in order for it to go to
the President's desk I get that that's
not inspiring right like you know
fighting a holding action is not does
not rally the troops but it's a lot
better than not you know then losing
those holding actions right so so keep
in mind staying in place is often is is
a benefit compared to where we've been
over the past two years so I would put
that kind of as number one the second
thing that I would point out is that
there has been a difference particularly
in the Senate Intelligence Committee
versus the House Intelligence Committee
right like both are controlled by
Republicans the Senate Intelligence
Committee is is controlled by Richard
burr of North Carolina and and they have
moved forward with the investigation
whether there was Russian collusion in
the 2016 elections and Russian efforts
to you know tamper with with the
elections and I think that's an again
look like you know Richard burr snow if
no friend of mine and and nobody that
we're likely to be lauding on our
respective shows now but but the Senate
Intelligence Committee is run by
grown-ups right the House Intelligence
Committee was run by you know a pack of
howler monkeys on the far right that
literally the House Intelligence report
was was a joke right I mean it it
completely exonerated Trump and so when
I think about the the the area that that
I would want to move forward in terms of
investigatory and oversight power
I think it's on that national security
issue right I think there are
Republicans yes they're terrified of
Trump they're terrified of being primary
by you know a trump or that that is
going to cost them more than siding with
Trump in the general election that's the
underlying dynamics of the electorate
that we have to change but but
fundamentally like I think Richard burr
cares about whether the Russians are
hacking or elections I can't say that
about the house freedom caucus right and
thankfully they lost in their app so we
certainly can't say it about Devon
newness yeah yeah yeah exactly
so you know it I don't want on the one
hand right I definitely get it when when
allies my folks on the left and people
in the resistance movement talk about
the Overton Window right like you do you
don't want to normalize shifting things
to the right but at the same time I
think that it is important to
differentiate between Senate Republicans
again they got they marched in lockstep
behind Trump on the 2017 tax bill they
they are you no no no friends of
progressives but I think they're
different than the House Republicans and
and so that that that's why I think that
that's a huge victory there last thing I
want to touch on today the tax returns
Trump's tax returns there are now
discussions of okay now maybe there is a
way to get access to these
the left forget about that in other
words what what what at this point would
we gain and I'm not saying I don't want
to see them I think there would be
incredibly damaging things there but the
thing is that the Republicans don't seem
to care Republican voters don't seem to
care I just wonder if it's worth
spending the political capital yeah um
that's a really really great question
and it it also sets me up to plug my
show again I did a I did a two-part
episode in which I brought on a
corporate accountant and we talked about
the kinds of things that you might see
and might not see on the tax returns and
and I would summarize that down to say
if they're given the number of privately
held LLC's and shell corporations that
Donald Trump has getting his personal
tax returns is very likely to give us an
incomplete or no picture right like
there is a ton of evidence that is going
to be easy to bury even in even if we do
get his personal tax returns now that
being said I think we should give us tax
returns all right and and and there is a
provision of the IRS code that
explicitly authorizes the house
investigatory committee do disclose tax
returns to other House committees or to
the Senate I talked about this on my
show recently and once that has been
disclosed there is a principle in the
law it's called the testimonial
privilege and basically what that means
is that sitting members of the House and
the Senate are immune from lawsuit for
any actions they undertake on the floor
of Congress in connection with their job
right so in other words if if the house
gets and they will get it will be under
seal will be a confidential copy of
Trump's tax returns then they publish it
to another House committee that can then
be read into the Congressional Record
and will then be a matter of public
record and there's nothing that Trump
can do to stop that the the most famous
example of that occurred in the 1970s
the early 1970s that when the Pentagon
Papers case was pending before the
Supreme Court and Alaska Senator Mike
Gravel
read
the entire Pentagon Papers a
filibustered and read the entire
Pentagon Papers into the record on the
floor of the Senate
thus you know if essentially moving the
case then the next day the Supreme Court
decided that the New York Times could
publish the Pentagon Papers anyway but
but yeah so it in terms of spending the
political capital I think that this is
it's not going to be difficult the IRS
is required to turn over pursuant to
statute and then and then you can
publish with him within the house now
you have to be concerned politically
about about a backfire effect right so
but but I certainly would would
encourage Elijah Cummings who's going to
be the new chair of that committee and
who has said that you know he intends to
use his investigate Ori powers to to
request the tax returns totally
straightforward should get them in
January that is something something to
look forward to huh definitely check out
the opening arguments show we've been
speaking with Andrew Torres who is
co-host of the opening arguments show
graduate of Harvard Law has been
practicing for 21 years it's getting you
know I think it was 21 years the first
time you were on it's got to be like 22
or 23 by now yeah it's 22 now but no
thank you so much for having me on David
I I I love what you're doing I love your
voice out there I'm really really
excited to see how the show has taken
off and and and I always love coming on
and chatting about these issues with you
even if even if I'm you know sometimes
throwing some cold water out there but
thanks for having me on